[music]
You need
Now I think
Thank you.
[music]
It's probably
You guys, I've have like a fouryear-old.
>> Is Maitlyn coming in here?
Okay, I set this up for us. What do we
think?
>> You should like shuffle my order.
>> Okay, wait. What is the order though?
>> John 6.
>> John 6. I got that song.
>> Your song.
>> Draw me close.
>> John 6. Draw me close.
>> Your mom.
>> Okay. So, I got
>> Would you just
So, we're closing the car
and then
>> Hey, welcome to the table. We're so glad
you're here. Tonight is special because
it's youth Sunday and our table teens,
including me, will be leading the
service. Well, okay. If you're
interested in becoming a member of the
table or simply want to learn more about
who we are, we'd love to have you join
us for our next Welcome to the Table
class on Sunday, November 16th from 3:00
to 4:30 p.m. RSVP by scanning the QR
code on the screen. Okay. Her next
service day for Five Loves Food Pantry
will be Saturday, December 6th from 9:15
a.m. to 12:00 p.m. They're asking for
all volunteers to sign up to be
registered by November 17th to ensure
that all profiles and waiverss are done
and ready to go. Please scan the QR code
to sign up.
If you're anxious about being in a
church setting, are part of a disability
community, or are just feeling fidgety
today, we have an accessibility bucket
to my left on the table. There are
noiseancelling headphones, fidgets, and
coloring sheets. We ask that you return
them to the bucket at the end of the
service. Now is the call to worship.
These candles are a sign of the presence
of Christ among us, fully divine, and
fully human. Now we exit exit the
kingdom of noise, hurry, and
productivity. Now we enter the kingdom
of silence, stillness, and simplicity. A
sacred space, a place for prayer,
worship, and adoration. A place to
behold Christ. Revelation of God.
Heartbeat of creation. Allow the
unforced rhythms of grace to find you,
to mend your heart. May we all come
home.
[music]
>> Hey guys, we're going to open with a new
song called John [music] 6. Um, and we
hope that you guys will join in as you
feel comfortable and go ahead and stand
[music] with us.
It doesn't matter [music] if the home
turns
away. I will stay with you, my God.
[music]
I will stay with you.
And it doesn't matter [music] if
turns around. I will stay with you, my
God. [music]
Sing that again. It doesn't matter.
[music]
I will stay with [music and singing]
you.
I will stay with you.
It doesn't matter. [music]
Turn [singing]
away. [music] I will stay with you, my
God.
I will stay with [music and singing]
you. with you.
Where can I go? Where can I go? [music]
Where can I go? [singing]
[music]
Where can I [singing] go
when only [music] you
only
[music]
Stay with my God.
I will stay with you. [music]
Where can I go? Where [singing] can I
go? Where can I go?
[music]
Only you
only. [music]
Where can I go? Where can I go? Where
can I [music] go?
>> [singing]
>> Only you are the words of only you.
[music]
Only you are the words of only you.
For the world's going [singing] to
satisfy.
For the world's going [music] to be
mine. For the love that I'm turning,
Jesus, you're [music] praise.
For the world's going to satisfy.
For the world's going to be
[music and singing] my
love that I'm turning to. Jesus, you're
going to break [music and singing] free.
No going to satisfy.
No other world's [music] going to be my
life. No other [singing] that I'm
turning to. Jesus, [music]
you're my
world's [singing] going to say, [music]
world's going to be my
love that [music] turn.
Jesus, you're my
[music] Jesus, you're my
Jesus, you're my breakthrough.
Oh Jesus, you're my breakthrough.
[music]
It doesn't matter if the whole [music]
world turns
away. I will stay [singing] with you, my
God. God, I [music] will stay with you.
It [singing] doesn't matter. The world
[music]
turns away. I will stay with you, my
God.
I will stay [music and singing] with
you.
Where can I go? Where can I go? [music]
Where can I go? Where can I go?
[singing]
When only you have the [music] words of
only you hold the words
where [music] can I go? Where [singing]
can I go? Where can I go?
When only you hold the
[music and singing] words of life? Only
you hold the words.
Only you hold the words [music] of life.
Only [singing] you hold the words of
life. Only [music]
you hold the words of love. Only you
hold the words.
All right, kiddos. You are dismissed to
go to your classes. You can see your way
over to those double doors and your
teachers will meet you there to walk you
back. [music] Thank you so much to our
kids ministry volunteers who are serving
tonight back there with our kids. We
greatly appreciate you, [music] Katie,
Abby, Rhysa, and Nancy. Thank you. Thank
you.
All right. [music] Tonight we are going
to participate in something that
throughout Christian history has been
known as prayers [music] of the people.
We will begin by reading a prayer aloud
together and then we'll leave space for
you to say a name or situation [music]
you would like us to hold in prayer
before God. We ask that you only say
their name.
>> For the city [music] of Saxi, Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. [music]
We pray to you for the good earth you
have given us and the wisdom and the
will to [music] conserve it. We pray to
you for the old and the sick, for the
widowed and the orphan. [music]
For the injured and suffering, we pray
to you for the poor and the oppressed,
the unemployed [music] and destitute,
for prisoners and captives, and all who
remember and care for them. We pray
[music] to you for the vulnerable,
marginalized, and those unjustly
targeted for their gender, [music]
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you, [music]
God. We know that you love us and that
you hear us. So, we lift these names and
situations up [music] to you.
For the names [music] and the moments we
have spoken aloud and for those we have
kept in our hearts, we pray to you that
they may have life [music] and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep
[music] sense of your presence. Amen.
>> Draw me [music] close to you.
Never let me go.
I lay [singing] it all down [music]
again.
to hear you say that I'm your friend.
You are [music and singing] my desire.
[music] No one else will do
[music] nothing [singing] else.
to feel the warmth of
[singing and music] your embrace.
Help me find the way.
Bring me back [music and singing] to
you.
Oh, [music]
[singing] you're all
You're all there.
You're all [music]
I want.
Help me know [music] you are near.
Draw me close to you.
[music]
Never let me go.
[music] I'll lay it all down [singing]
again
to hear you say that I'm your friend.
You are my desire.
No one else will do
cuz nothing else can take your place
[music]
to feel the warmth of your embrace.
Help me find a way
to bring [music] me back [singing] to
you.
Oh, [music and singing]
you're all I want.
[music and singing]
You're all I've ever
needed. [music]
You're all [singing]
I want.
Help
[music and singing] me know you are
near. You're all I want.
[music] You're all [singing]
I've ever
needed. [music]
You're [singing] all I want.
Help me know you are here. Help
[music]
me know you are.
Help me know you
need.
How we bring [music] you the work of our
hands. Now lay it down.
[music and singing] Lay it at your feet.
what [music] we've built, what we've
done, what we've broken.
Lay it down, [singing] lay it at your
feet.
You hold it all,
Jesus. [music and singing] You hold
it all.
>> [music]
>> Worried hearts, weary. We can bies.
[music and singing]
Lay it down. Lay it at your [singing]
feet. [music]
What we've used, what we've lost, what
we've wasted. [music]
Lay it down. [singing] Lay it at your
feet.
You hold [music]
it all,
Jesus. You [music] hold it all.
You hold [music and singing]
it all, Jesus. You hold it home.
All our dreams, [music]
all our plans, our ambition.
Lay it [music and singing] down. Lay it
at your feet.
[music] And even if [singing]
nothing comes to fruition,
[music] lay it down. [singing] Lay it at
your feet.
Lay it down. Play it at your feet.
>> Bow your heads and let's talk to God for
a second.
God, thank you for [music] being here
with us today. Sometimes we know that
you're here in our heads before we feel
it in our hearts. And I know that that's
okay. But today, we just want to feel
you close.
Not because [music] it's what we earned,
because we deserve it. but because
you're good and that you love us.
So if there's anyone here who feels
[music] tired or overwhelmed or off
today, would you please meet them here
in your house, Lord? Even if it's small,
for a sense of peace. We're choosing to
trust you with whatever we're carrying.
And God, we're asking, help us feel
unique. [music]
Let your presence wash over us and
ground us here in your love today. Amen.
Amen. Now, could you each please turn to
someone next to you and play and say,
[music] "May the peace of Christ be with
you.
Hello, welcome everybody. We're so glad
to have you. Tonight we're going to be
having the youth Sunday and I will be
your MC for this evening.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Yes. And a round
of applause for our panel. They this
will be kind of a talk show style
riffing off some questions. Um I have
about uh three main questions in this
sermon presentation, but as we kind of
go through them, I also encourage you to
kind of take what uh is being presented
and maybe apply it to yourself and um
just kind of thinking uh we've been kind
of uh reflecting on these questions the
last week or so. Um, but it's also been
uh through our Bible study. But, um, uh,
with that, I'd like to, uh, pass it to
the panel to introduce themselves.
>> Hello, my name is Kieran. Uh, my
pronouns are he, him, and I'm 14.
>> Hi, my name is August. My pronouns are
she, her, and I just turned 16 on
Thursday. And I did fail my driver's
test, but
I'm so sorry. Uh oh, my name is Hank
Humble. I am 17. Um but uh with that, we
are the youth group. We meet up uh
there's a bunch of other members, too,
but uh we're the ones that will be
talking today. But we meet uh most
evenings uh on Sunday after the sermon,
kind of like 6:30 to 8ish. But uh it's a
it's a sacred time. Uh we got snacks, we
got games, we got Bible study. Uh it's
it's a real good time. And we we
definitely put a lot of focus on the
snacking games. But uh uh at least by
the end of every evening, we like to cap
it off with at least a little reflective
time. Even if maybe we're not focusing
as much on the Bible, it's still a
prayer time, a time for us to share how
we've been feeling, what we've been
doing. And when we even when we do get
to the Bible study, it's a really
freeing because it's honestly um a space
where you can feel the freedom to be
critical of the scripture or even just
express like what you're feeling or what
uh thoughts go through your mind. Um
sometimes it's a little iffy because the
language can be tricky. But with that,
uh I'd like to pass this question along
to all of y'all. Um, what are some key
moments from the Bible studies y'all
have reflected on?
>> Um, so we've been learning about
parables recently, and the one that
stuck with me most was the parable of
the sewer where he like um scattered
like seeds in different like ground on
like a path um like a rocky ground,
thorny ground and then on like good
soils. And it kind of like is to
represent how um people like interpret
God's word differently. And like
um what stuck out to me was like how in
some like environments like God's word
can be like interpreted like badly or
just like differently than like what
other people like intend it as. And it's
like yeah, it's just like different to
me. And like the way
the way I like to like when I'm Bible
studying um and learning about like
God's word, I like to like journal while
I do it because sometimes it can like
seem like it's over my head or just like
I won't be able to understand it. But if
I like write down what I'm thinking,
it's like easier for me to like
like know what I'm feeling about it.
This is a hard question for me to
answer. I don't know many parables or
stories in the Bible. Uh I haven't been
here long, so
I haven't been able to
hear many in youth group.
>> I appreciate your honesty. That's a
really good answer. Um yeah, it can be
really uh hard to grapple with the
scripture, especially with just how many
sources and places it can be learned
from. it can be so much of a contrasting
message. I really appreciate you all
sharing. Um this slide up here you can
kind of see I put together. Um, we've
been mostly focusing on Matthew's
parables, but uh, what I found
interesting, especially uh, in
preparation for this sermon, going
through like Chad GPT, uh, comparisons
of like the Greek translations and then
like where the the Old Testament to the
New Testament going from Hebrew, it's
like really
convoluted. Um it um is interesting was
the kind of contrasting of the tonal
shift between like Matthew and Luke. You
can see tax collector and the um
physician. Um Matthew has a very strong
like right and wrong. I put the parable
of two sons in comparison to the parable
of the prodigal son. like the two sons,
it was showing action and inaction.
Where where you gonna be when it comes
down to the the breast axe, but then
Luke was a lot more of his message were
focused on like just this like in the
prodigal son, he's like, "This is my son
who has been lost, but he's back." And
it's just like it feels like you can get
a lot of different um just
interpretations of uh God's grace. So
sometimes it can be hard for me. Um it
can feel almost problematic. Um
sometimes like some of the texts like
even um the sheep and the goats I felt
like the
verbiage of like uh you'll be cast off
into the place prepared for the devil
and his demons. It's like whoa what is
this like
judgment day? Um it's very clear that uh
different thoughts going on. Um, but
when we go through it, it can be it can
get really caught up in the scripture,
but um, I like to think more on what
it's actually telling us as far as how
we need to be carrying our lives on. So,
with that, I kind of bring that into the
question of when you think on Christ's
character, what are some qualities or
actions that come to mind?
Uh some qualities that come to mind for
me is that he is very forgiving.
>> I don't know what else to add on that.
>> Very compassionate.
>> Forgiving.
>> That's awesome.
When I think of some of God's quality, I
think of like patience and gentleness
and like just limitless love and sorry
and like I feel like I can like see or
like
I don't know and like moments of my life
when I'm in the presence I feel like I
can like forget that and just feel like
like I don't notice those qualities but
then like when I look back on my life
I'm like wow like there's just so much
patience patience and gentleness that he
brings to me in my life
and yeah and I just feel very fortunate
looking back and I think that that's
I don't know
>> it's very admirable instilling the fruit
of the spirit
>> love joy peace patience
>> uh that's awesome um with this I've been
kind of trying to prepare the sermon for
uh how can we kind of think about this
in a way where it's a little more easy
and palatable. Uh, I've been kind of
reading this one book called The
Connection Codes. Um, I was trying to
think, how do I put a good sermon? Well,
I know a lot of them have at least a few
excerpts from some books. Um, but this
one is another one of those good ones
for understanding people and their um
just kind of reasoning behind why we get
in these patterns and thoughts. Um, it
kind of just can be summed up by like
the Inside Out movie. You don't really
have to read it, but um, it was it was a
good one to read. Um, I felt it was
really cool when uh it kept up this
consistent message of keeping up these
cycles of emotions and really
experiencing that like even um guilt and
shame. are sound like terrible emotions
but they're important for us to fully
process as far as um like a child it
gave an example is a child feels the
guilt of a wrong question or math and
then after that they learn oh I need to
make this right but it can the negative
manifestations can become anxiety and
depression that's where it's more of the
human side of um just these toxic cy
cycles of the fear of what will happen
and the fear to process what has
happened and not ever staying really
truly present. Um, and we're it was
broke it down that we're kind of simple
beings. We're a little primitive at
times. We are focused on a search for
dopamine. even if it's just to um
fulfill our and affirm our lifestyles,
it can um it's what keeps us motivated
even if we're trying to keep our family
safe or eat the right foods. It it
can all work towards a Christlike
attitude, but we have to remember that
we are human and that's kind of why we
slip up so much. Um, we're designed to
seek connection and thrive with those
around us. And fortunately, that's why
we're able to kind of push through. And
fortunately, we experience the most
fulfillment when we're connecting with
each other and being good neighbor.
[laughter]
>> [snorts]
>> So with that, I present that to one of
our capstone questions of how we can
actually apply this and really instill
these better behaviors. Uh where does
your heart go when you see great loss
and condemnation around you? And in my
subtext, does this speak to God? How God
has designed our inner beings? Do we
already have the tools we need?
Um yeah, for me when I like witness
great loss or see bad things happening
in my life, I tend to like just kind of
shut down and like be quiet about it and
like I don't know. It's just not very
productive. It's not really what I want
to do, but just kind of what seems
easiest at moments. But I don't know. I
think like after like once I've sat with
my like just quietness for a while, I
like the way that helps me like
become more productive I guess is like
if I'm like journaling or if I actually
talk to somebody about like how I'm
feeling it like can help me like find
ways to like
just like help whatever is like whatever
bad is happening in my life and like
just get through it better.
Uh for me
um
it's a bit
sort of disappointing to see how people
can be towards each other.
Um I like to think of them as like
bullies.
uh most of the times something is going
on with them and it's important to
understand that
but it doesn't excuse the behavior. It's
important to recognize that
something could be going wrong in
someone's life,
but it doesn't
warrant
for others to take it out on others.
>> That's important to keep in mind. It is
really uh shines to instilling like a a
positive spirit and I think that's very
strong.
I think it's the it's the golden ticket.
What it's the main question, but um it
really instills how we carry ourselves
and put to action a truly compassionate
life. Um with that, I would like to
thank you for your time. Um it was I had
a lot of notes putting this together. It
was a little blurry, but um I it was
stressful putting it together, I must
say, but um I had a lot of fun in the
end and um I was excited to present this
to y'all.
Yes. But thank thank you and let's give
a round of applause to our wonderful
panel. [applause]
With that, I think we're leading into
the Celtic call. Um, this is the table,
not of the church, but of the Lord. It's
made ready for those who love him, those
who want to love him more. So, come you
who have much faith and you who have
little. You who have been here often,
you have not been here long. You who
have tried to follow, you who have
failed, come because it's Lord and
invites you. And it's he that it is his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come.
Let's
get back.
>> [music]
>> As I rise,
strength of God,
go before,
lift me up
as I
Heart eyes of God
look upon
[music] be my [singing] side
as I wait
Heart of God
satisfied
and sustained
as I hear
voice of God.
Lead me on.
Be my God. [music]
Be my God.
Above [music and singing]
and below me, before and behind me, in
every [music and singing] eye that sees
me. Christ be all around me, [music]
above and below [singing] me, before and
behind me, in every [singing] eye that
sees me. Christ be all around
[singing and music] me. Yeah.
Oh,
[music]
as I go
of God,
[music] my defense [singing]
on my side
as I live
and God
fall
me peace. Peace.
Bring me peace
above and below [music and singing] me,
before and behind me, in every eye that
sees [music and singing]
me. Christ be all around me, above and
below [music and singing] me, before and
behind me, in every eye that sees
[music] me. Christ be all around me.
Yeah. Oh. [music and singing]
Oh.
[music] Christ be all around me.
[singing]
Yeah. Oh. [music]
Oh. [singing]
[music]
Christ be all around me.
Yeah.
Your life, [music]
your [singing] death, your blood was
shed for every moment. [music]
every moment. Your life, [music] your
[singing] death, your blood was shed.
For every moment,
every [singing]
moment, your [music] life, your death,
your [singing] blood was shed [music]
for every moment.
every [music]
moment. Your life, [singing] your death,
your blood [music] was shed for every
moment.
Every moment, [music]
above and [singing] below me, [music]
before and behind me, in every [singing]
eye that sees me. Christ be [music] all
around me, above and below me, before
[music and singing] and behind me, in
every eye that sees me. Christ be
[music and singing] all around me. Yeah.
Oh,
oh, [singing]
Christ be [music] all around [singing]
me.
Oh
[music]
[singing] wo
Christ be all around me. [singing]
Thank you [music] so Oh, thank you so
much for joining us this evening. If
you're new, we would love for you to
fill out a car card at the table on your
way out or just scan the [music] QR code
on the screens to fill out the online
visitor card. Thank you so much for
[music] coming to the Youth Sunday. Have
a great night.
[music]
>> And she's introducing me to do the
benediction. [laughter]
Y'all hang with us for a second. We'll
get mail a mic.
[applause and music]
>> Hello. Oh,
all right. Let me send you off uh into
your week with this blessing. [music]
You could hold out your hand in a
posture of receiving or you could just
open up your heart for these words. You
are a child of God. You are a child of
God. This is true on your best day and
this is [music] especially true on your
worst day. So as you go into this week
ahead with it yet to be determined highs
[music] and lows and everything in
between, go filled with the assurance
that you are loved, you are worthy, and
you are accepted just as you are.
[music]
and go filled with the Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Thank you
[music] for coming and I hope to see you
guys all next week.
[applause]
[music]
You are dismissed.
Above and below me, before and behind
me, in every eye that
[music and singing] sees me. Christ be
all around me, above and below me,
before [music and singing] and behind
me, in every eye that sees me. Christ be
all around [singing and music] me.
Oh,
[music] oh, [singing]
Christ [music] be all around me.
>> [singing]
>> Oh, [music]
Christ be all around [singing]
me.
>> Thank you. The table. Thank you, city of
Saxi.
>> It's okay. Everything has its little
tick.
>> I literally
I would not do that
myself.